alors dit moi qu'est-ce qui fait comme
travail ton papa wemba peut-être
chauffeur de taxi me fait rien
[Musique]
peut-être mais pas la publicité
attention attention à la banane à tout
va tout au nom
attention non mais ça va prendre comment
ça ça va pas non moi j'en veux pas vous
venez à l'arrière c'est à moi non je
n'en veux pas allons bon c'est pas la
peine d'insister j'en veux pas ouais
d'accord et vous en voulez ou pas alors
non je n'en veux pas d'accord et je vais
mais où
tout est fermé ou alors bon non nulle
part non mais tu pauvre affamé chose qu
les choses garder un non non non non non
je lui dis je vous ai cru je croyais
plus tôt et attention à la lampe est
bousillée votre peinture maintenant
c'est ça il faut l'enlever avec un
karcher non m'en veux et je vous ai dit
pas la même patrouille est à dire et
dabs la voiture tu mets ça dessus ouais
tu vois les voitures qui font un peu
efféminé tu mets des trucs dessus quoi
et ça ça fait une voiture efféminé
rocher pour moi j'y connais rien en
voiture dans entendu ce que je t'ai dit
oui je veux pas de publicité dans ma
d'accord alors tu vas voir ailleurs et
puis tu te casses monique jamais ou
alors quoi tu te fais chier la tue tu
comprends pas où il faut que je te le
disent qu'ils cachent lâche-moi d'accord
en plus kiev m
faire pocher gaiffe m ouais donc je
propose aux personnes non il n'y a pas
de honte quand on a pas le droit ah bon
et interdit à l'est
rédaction on parle beaucoup de change ah
bon c'est pas la corporation pour allah
josée couture
allez peut-être que c'est pas les leurs
hier gendarmes et des gays
c'est pas vrai voici l'été à la reine de
koné la reine
époque et alors
je débute mois
regardez vous le mettez chez vous non ma
frappe à la porte ah bon elle ne sait
pas de quoi votre femme je vais le taxi
[Musique]